wouldn't be my first choice I am a
sucker for fortune cookies you know I
thought it would be a good idea if we
all talked this over like adults what do
you want the same thing I've always
wanted to bring light into the dark to
bring life where there is death we're
all your talk of life sure kill a lot of
people
Luke Cage Jessica Jones the devil of
Hell's Kitchen
the Iron Fist I can see you formed on
here I promise you it's temporary
they will disappoint you and if I might
give you some advice
the more connections you have the easier
it will be to Rachel
you need to think that through
[Music]
New York go densely-populated
you know your way out of here's to
gether
you
it's just City you'll get used to
watching them fall
Debbie why to go
let's go ahead clad it burns yet I know
hey everybody defenders is dropping
tonight this is going to be my
non-spoilery review I've seen the first
four episodes I'll start doing spoilery
videos after the episodes start dropping
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and I will be doing a Marvel giveaway so
because this is Netflix why don't we say
for a Netflix subscription so all you
have to do to enter that just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but this last trailer which all
referenced during this actually does a
good job of setting up the premise of
the season normally these four people
would have no business coming together
they come from such different
backgrounds all of their personalities
couldn't be more different from each
other and it's a little bit like the
Avengers when they first came together
that was sort of the tagline it's like
these people are almost gods in their
own individual worlds in his
neighborhood Matt Murdock is the devil
of Hell's Kitchen he's the demon that
rules that place the criminals are
afraid of but he goes up to Harlem where
Luke Cage is from it tries to go up
against Diamondback he would get put on
his ass
especially considering the Diamondback
is now probably just as super-powered as
Luke cages but purple man is another
good example - Jessica Jones is also
from Hell's Kitchen but thankfully he
was a pervert and only wanted to go
after women and flashy things so
daredevil wasn't even on his radar but
thank the Marvel gods that they were
able to get Sigourney Weaver probably
one of the best actresses working today
Kumbi this very real-world New York
villain that there's a really good job
of tying the series together like she's
the one thing that everybody has in
common and that she wants to take all of
New York all the different boroughs and
she sort of has her hands in the pie of
each of the villains from the different
series so not only does she sort of tie
the heroes together she also ties all
the villains together too but that's
largely through the hand organization so
you've seen them a couple different
times some of you may not be up on every
single series you don't have to watch
all the TV shows before you watch
defenders that's why you know one of the
complaints especially from the first
four episodes is that they take a little
while to spin things up they don't get
together right away and that's because
they take time to visit each of the
different heroes in their own
neighborhood
and let you know what they've been doing
since the end of the last season of
their TV series some of them have only
had one season
some people like daredevil have had to
once they do come together all the
actors are fantastic
iron fist is even made much better by
the presence of the other actors and
their personalities you've probably seen
a bunch of the jokes that they make in
the trailers Jessica Jones probably one
of the funniest characters in this she
and daredevil are still my favorites
like Luke Cage is amazing Mike Colter is
great as that character but I still like
the daredevil character a lot more like
I have a giant stack of daredevil comics
maybe I have like 10 or 20 Luke Cage
comics but part of the delight of taking
their time and doing all this character
work is you get some really weird
pairings that you normally wouldn't get
like I said all their personalities are
super different so when they come
together it just makes for some really
good moments like I've been hyping up
daredevil on Jessica Jones together they
are one of my favorite pairs and then
obviously the pairs that everybody's
hoping they eventually get to is Heroes
for Hire Luke Cage iron fist if you've
read the comics it's a bit of a surprise
the way they start off or maybe it's not
a surprise because they're not super
best friends and even Luke Cage said in
the previous trailer I'm not looking for
any Super Friends and of all of them
iron fist is the only one who's really
thinking about the threat of the hand
and them coming together he's super
jazzed up about it but all the other
scoff at it Jessica Jones of course has
the best reactions she just calls
[ __ ] on everything unless she has
that joke at the end of this trailer
about iron fist come on iron clad that's
not my name oh I totally know she makes
fun of Daredevils costume you know Luke
Cage also made fun of his own costume
too so every Iron Fist meme you've ever
seen they take every opportunity to poke
fun at that in part of the fun of the
series once they come together is how
they react to each other particularly
iron fist because his personality is so
different from the other members because
pretty much all of them come from the
streets like think about their
backgrounds they all come from nothing
they visit these crazy tragic events
iron fist has spent most of his time in
this very protected sacred land of
Kunlun so even though he's been through
some big trials he's been so removed
from the real world for so long that he
just doesn't process things the way the
others do like if you lived in Hell's
Kitchen your entire life you would react
very differently from so
one like Iron Fist who spent his entire
life training to defeat this
organization I haven't seen too many
people talk about the big action
set-pieces but obviously it takes them a
little while to come together so while
there is a couple really cool action
moments in each of the episodes leading
up to the first time that they come
together the choreography is great even
the actor that plays Iron Fist is very
honest about the way he wasn't super
happy about the choreography during his
first season they've largely fixed a lot
of those problems but all in all I feel
like most people are going to walk away
from this being really excited like okay
this is awesome we haven't gotten this
in a TV show before there been big
crossovers like if you watch the DC TV
shows they do big crossovers every
season this is even bigger than that and
I feel like the performances are even
better but you will walk away wondering
why there's only eight episodes of this
but we sat through 13 hours of iron fist
so you'd be like okay maybe they should
switch this around next time do eight
episodes of each of the individual
series in 13 episodes of defenders
season 2 if they've been really coy
about what's happening next after this
there's a post-credits scene so make
sure you stick around after the last
episode and they have Punisher that's
coming up in the middle of November so
once we get through defenders I'll start
talking more about punisher stuff
they'll start dropping more trailers so
we have a whole bunch of Marvel stuff
that's coming this fall we have Thor
Ragnarok we have an infinity war trailer
like a genuine infinity war trailer and
then all of punisher so it's going to be
great they're really subtle during
defenders with their big comic book
references so if you haven't read the
defenders comic book before it's a
little bit different it's a different
roster and yes it does feel very much
like daredevil Shadowland but obviously
so much has been changed from the comics
before this is built on all the other
series so of course it's very different
from those other comic book arcs but
there is a lot of comic book Easter eggs
sprinkled throughout but they didn't do
any specific comic book storyline but if
you're looking you will see all those
Easter eggs I'll try to point them out
when I start posting the spoilery videos
so what I'll probably do for my next
defenders video is just a spoiler video
for the first block of episodes and then
I'll break it up into two episode blocks
and then just depending on how many
videos you guys want for each of the
episodes so just listen to feedback as
things roll out but these are to check
it out as fast
possible if you can binge it all tonight
then more power to you but it's going to
be awesome I am generally really hyped
up about the rest like I said I've only
seen the first four episodes and I have
a feeling that the stuff that I've seen
is only a taste of the big crazy stuff
that they're rolling out Sigourney
Weaver Jessica Jones daredevil
definitely might stand out favorites
from the first couple of episodes but
they sort of ramp up the crazy and they
do take their time the first couple of
episodes explaining the logic of what's
going on with the characters so I think
that's mostly for the benefit of people
that did not watch Jessica Jones or
didn't watch daredevil or didn't watch
Luke Cage you get the idea but once you
do have a chance to see it let me know
in the comments what do you think of it
so far who's your favorite characters
from the first couple of episodes and
let me know in the comments if there are
any special videos that you guys want me
to do outside of the normal episode
videos so while you wait for everything
you can click here for more defenders
and Punisher and you can click here for
brand new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight